the heck?
How did that happen? That's bizarre.
That is very weird.
Well, don't I feel stupid?
Hello, Jess.
We're doing a little bit of science, a
little bit of experiments. Just a super
quick stream here.
Um, hour, maybe two hours.
This is literally the low point of the
whole training block that I've done.
Like, this is the day where I'm the most
exhausted and like I can barely think
straight.
Apparently, that's good for business
because the business side stuff I've
done in the last couple days worked very
well. Apparently, if I just have no
capacity to think about anything, things
go well.
If only research works that way.
So I think technically today is the um
today is the worst day because I had to
train this morning, right? So I burn
like nearly 1,000 calories training and
then I've already burnt my breakfast by
the time I get it. Um so tomorrow,
Saturday is my day off training.
I probably I get a little bit of extra
as well because I have to run uh do my
long run on Sunday and then after my
long run on Sunday, I'm done. So,
probably I'm not going to be back up to
full capacity tomorrow. I'm not going to
be able to like do this stuff all day,
but I have some errands to run anyways
and such. I'm going to aim just to get
like a few good hours of work in
tomorrow. Um and then we'll see from
there.
I did take some business classes while I
was at MIT since Sloan was right there.
And that's all it took to convince me I
did not want a non-technical co-founder.
Uh, this is sus, right?
This is sus.
This is weird how we have this one and
this one are both above 20.
Good chance we can get some of the
improvements into the drone. M got more
pit controller instead of just poor
position. Let me go check that other
thing for you, Kvert.
I did send a followup.
Let me go check for you.
All right, I got half a reply. I'll go
fish for the other half for you. I could
set up a meeting, but he didn't give me
a budget yet.
This is to be clear for a more general
shtick, right? The RL side work
for like custom sim work like RL side
work, this bar for that is a little
higher. We want like one at least one
like pretty major end of project done.
generally like something where I would
have to look at it and I wouldn't be
able to guess all the details from
looking at it.
something on the level of like
terraform or
I mean impulse war is very impressive
but I guess the only thing with Impulse
War is it wasn't really finished right
because it didn't have like good bots
with it.
The sim for that is more than good
enough but the bots aren't there.
So there you go.
Such a screwy little thing with this,
isn't it?
So, what we can do though, let me put
this here.
Think small thoughts today, Joseph. Do
not think big thoughts. You are too
stupid to think big thoughts today.
H
me want to do compute data trade-off
analysis
caveman RL update times.
H
all have high frame skip.
That very weird.
Hey Carlos, we are doing a little tiny
bit of
analysis today
on some existing experiments. Going to
launch some new ones and that is it.
weird.
like no correlation with any of this
This is a little bit of a correlation.
Not much,
but that's not the correlation in the
direction I wanted or expected at least.
I mean, if there if this point where the
were not here, it would be a different
story. But like, yeah,
this is so odd.
this makes it a lot denser even if it's
quite the same quality, right?
Oh, really? That's so weird. Look at
that. It just adds like these few points
in.
I should know by now how weird RL is
though.
Was the most California thing ever. I
can't even drink my coffee. You see this
paper straw plastic cup
there?
Pop off of this and drink it.
What do we do though? What do we do
about this?
I mean, we do have
we have our data points. It's just not
like a front like we would want it.
I want to know this one is
20.97.
Oh,
dummy.
There we go.
All right. So here is our magical
configuration.
Now I want to figure out why this thing
is so damn low right.
Um,
this doesn't look like it should be slow
at all to me. Right.
Oh, it's not going to give me the
output, is it?
that does solve it.
Why the hell is this what it found?
Bizaro. Is it actually this slow when I
have no other GPUs going? I'm going
through MDP and some math stuff
hard. Should I fully understand or just
use algorithms?
You should do neither of those two
things.
Follow my RL guide. It will give you the
correct level of detail.
Like the thing is, you're learning the
wrong details right now.
Okay. So, I mean, according to this,
this is the actual speed this thing runs
at.
like why the hell? My question is like,
why the hell?
this not just work if I do
am I stupid like this this works right
if I just do it like this or is it
inconsistent like something's wrong
right
Bro, you look tired.
Yeah, this is the
last This is the hardest day of my six
week absolutely psychotic cut and
training program. I'm streaming like an
hour or two worth of just basic analysis
that does not require me to think big
thoughts and I'm calling it.
I mean, I'll have the article. I'm
actually, this is one of the rare
personal articles I do put out there.
Um, that'll be out sometime next week,
and you'll see why I look so tired.
Absolutely brutal training program.
Like, horrendous.
All right. So, something weird happened
here. How? Why is this so slow?
Right. What happened?
Well, something's a mess, right? It
shouldn't be that slow.
The number of mini batches screwed up
somehow.
Let me go look.
So, I mean, it seems to me like
there's just like a speed diff
basically. So there's no compute data
tradeoff because for whatever reason my
fast config that's supposed to be three
mill steps a second isn't. And it could
just be hardware diff.
But like yeah
maybe you should use GPU. This is
running GPU my guy.
After running a sweeper, we better off
taking the learning rate close to the
best runner. Taking average
the best run coefficient.
Now, you definitely don't average
hypers. What you do is you find the best
stable run that doesn't look insane and
you take that one. And if that one's
jank and doesn't repro, you take a
different one.
A lot of this stuff is going to be a lot
more concrete like understanding deeply
deeply understanding hypers and stable
regions and stuff is one of the the key
goals here.
Let's see. I'm literally in the wrong
folder. That's how tired I am.
No, I think I'm still going to do
partial through Sunday. We'll see.
I'll probably get like a few extra
carbs, but I haven't I haven't decided
if I'm going to try to run a half
marathon on Sunday or not yet.
On one hand, it would be a really nice
way to end the training block. On the
other hand, like until I have like
proper carbs again, it's just brutal.
I'm in shape enough that a half marathon
should not even be that hard, but like
brutal as it is right now.
These are literally the same settings.
Math makes sense for Saturday.
Wait, the math go full strength worth
the day off.
I'm not sure yet.
Well, it's the thing is it's not like
I'm not actually going to be able to
think properly for a few days until I
get properly like it takes a couple
days.
Um, and then I have a bunch of in-person
work to do next week. So, look,
realistically, all the stuff I'm doing
here on the science side, this is just
bonus, right? Like, I didn't plan on
starting the new block of research until
I got back to the farm. I planned on
getting like, you know, one good block
of research done over uh over the summer
here and then a bunch of business. And
you know, I've gotten that done and I've
also gotten done um a little bit of a a
bonus head start on this next block. So,
we're ahead of schedule in all like in
all possible ways already.
I think this is literally what is
happening, right?
4096.
Let's hang on. Let me show Let me try
one thing here. Right.
So, we have eight frame skip.
This This is a solve. Let me just make
absolutely sure.
We're gonna I know what we're going to
do with this. I think this is just
hardware screwiness with small nets
being stupid.
Okay. 12 seconds. We only count we count
the up time to train. This next bit is
just evaluation. Okay.
I'm honestly tempted to look up like
what the hell is the most aggressive cut
that's actually used in pro
bodybuilding.
I wouldn't be surprised if I'm doing
that.
still research stream.
All right, we'll check real quick. Last
Grock. Oops.
I'm literally at the max end of this at
lower at at a lower body weight as well.
Yep. Okay.
Well,
certifiably batshit crazy.
Well, okay guys, apparently the
experiments are getting screwed up
because for this specific case, the 5090
isn't 20% faster than the 4090. It's
three times faster than the 4090.
Lovely.
Literally the entire reason it screwed
up.
Well,
No wonder we're getting crazy different
results.
They run at completely different speeds.
Chips both have freaking tensor cores.
Not supposed to be that much faster.
That's not how it's supposed to work.
Wait. So, does that mean Hang on. There
is one other thing I want to try.
You know, something unusual is happening
today.
I am
not functioning at all, but I'm still
having fun doing this.
Usually it's either I'm having fun and
functional or it sucks because I can't
get stuff done. But now it's kind of
like
Nope, Carlos. There it's using like
basically no memory either way.
It just so happens that when you have
things that run really fast anyways,
there can be really big discrepancies
because little tiny sources of overhead
that nobody cares about suddenly become
the main factor.
That is what is happening. Isn't that
great?
we'll do less than 2 mil and cost less
than 15.
You all have 20 seconds to guess what
I'm going to do for this experiment
before it becomes incredibly obvious.
If you guess take the optimized
hyperparameters on the slow machine and
run them on the fast machine,
congratulations.
You are correct.
yeah. Okay guys, apparently we can solve
Pong with freaking 10x less data in the
exact same amount of time.
So it's literally not even a hard work
qu work. There's just no bloody tradeoff
at all.
I mean, that's not like a that's not the
qualitative like nice curve I was hoping
for, but it's a good result.
If I wanted to look at the tradeoff and
there just isn't one, that's also fine,
right?
Wait, what happened? Oh, so instead of
using 12 million steps at eight frame
skip, we used 1 million frame uh 1
million steps at seven frame skip with
different hyperparameters and it solves
in the exact same amount of wall clock
time
Uh, the thing I was working on, yes,
there are dev branches with it, convert,
but no, it's not anything that you're
going to want to chuck on the drones.
What if you use those same hypers in the
nonfatal?
Wait, what do you mean the non fatal
reuse version?
What?
That's like
I don't even I don't know what you mean
even with it corrected though.
Oh yeah, these hyperparameters are
completely insane. Yeah. Oh, okay. Cool.
Well, wait a second then. Practically
doesn't this mean
Hang on.
Isn't the only like practical problem
that we have then just the fact that
this is not a lot of solve points?
Like it's really not coming up with
enough solves, right?
Like how many runs is this? This is a
lot of experiments worth of data, isn't
it?
Like if I just do this, how many data
points do we have?
Oh, well, we don't just don't have that
many data points for some bloody reason.
I let this run for a really long time,
though, didn't I?
Did it just get stuck somehow?
the algorithm that you're using says a
bit of data and reuse it.
No, this is not true, Carlos. That was
something that I was doing previously.
This algorithm is different from PO, but
not in that way.
Um, yeah, I let this thing run for a
very long time and it just didn't
produce us enough data.
That's super weird, right?
data it did produce is actually fine.
Like that's not even bad.
I thought it was the same thing. Nope.
You're conflating two different
projects.
So the save a little bit of data reuse.
That project is temporarily done. I have
a report on X. I have a full article on
it. And there is a thing that I can
revisit in the future with like a
different research block. This is a
hyperparameter compute data off trade
off a compute data trade-off thing.
How is it different from PO? Because
Puffer doesn't use PO anymore. We have
an article on this, right? We have our
own algorithm. The base of it looks like
PO. We have a lot of modifications
though. It works way better than PO when
you tune it.
This really doesn't make any sense at
all, does it?
Just you can draw the lines wherever you
want. Academics can debate over that. I
do not care. It's our algorithm. It
behaves differently. We use it.
It's a big enough difference if you just
say, "Oh yeah, they use PO." and you go
like implement PO and expect to get our
results, you won't get Um,
I mean really the only remaining problem
I have with this is it's slow then.
Yeah,
that would actually explain a lot.
Why does it do that though?
I have no idea why it's slow.
It's puffed up po, but it's puffed up a
lot.
Um, you can't really profile it, Carlos.
It's one of these things where like
it's definitely fast when I start it,
but I don't see any error either.
Unless I did something really stupid
like
Wait,
I have max runs.
Oh, you know what? This is it.
This is totally it. I'm just a dummy.
Yeah, I'm just a total dummy is all it
is. All right.
How much does model size scale with the
end complexity? I know we run small
models. Just wonder if there's a way to
optimize. If only I were working on
something that will answer that exact
question conclusively beyond the data
and evidence provided by any other work
in this field ever.
Yes, that's part of what we're doing
here.
I will be a lot less sardonic once I'm
eating again.
But yes, you're asking the exact right
question. It's just that I've already
asked it and now I am answering it.
On Sunday, I am getting myself
a steak and French toast after I do my
run.
I'm getting myself
I don't even want anything really. I
want a hamburger soup and a shake.
That's all I want.
[Music]
We're going to die in here.
100% self-inflicted,
but hey.
[Music]
And uh believe it or not, we are almost
done here already. Isn't that funny?
I basically know what experiments I want
to launch. All I have to do is launch
them. Isn't that nice?
Maybe we just do everything local. I
don't freaking know.
Yeah, like look at this. We already have
a ton of experiments here, right?
So much better.
This one too. All right. Well, we have
13 GPUs worth of experiments spinning.
So, I've done my job.
anything I can answer for folks here
real quick? If not, I'm just going to
keep this a quick stream
and then I will check back in on these
tomorrow.
Maybe do a little bit more tomorrow.
We'll see as well.
We hit 3.4K stars, which is pretty
awesome.
Yeah, all this stuff is on puffer.ai.
And if you're new around here, like most
of these M's are made by contributors,
even some of the fancier ones,
tons of helpful people on the Discord
and all of my educational content as
well as the research articles are on
Twitter and here.ai
or GitHub helps me out a lot.
Anybody else? Any questions,
burning concerns?
No.
Well, in that case, I am going to quit
while I'm ahead here.
And I'm going to take a hour and a half
before dinner to go do a few things.
And uh I will be back for at least a
decent chunk of time, I suppose,
tomorrow.
pivoting us. So easy. Yeah, I mean this
is honestly a year ago RL was the
hardest to get into branch of AI by a
mile. I've worked in NLP. I've worked in
vision. RL is just way harder. Um now we
have new programmers and hobbyists
getting into it. There's still a lot of
work to be done. There's still a lot of
core research that's still hard. But
barrier to entry way down. What's
possible? Way up. All right.